bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille guillaume chasse l'eau qui
est docteur en informatique
ancien ingénieur chez google créateur de
i'll go transparence y est actuellement
mozilla fellow bonjour guillaume bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté cette interview
est ce que tu peux commencer par un peu
de plantes et on peut planter ton
parcours professionnel et intellectuelle
donc voilà ouais là bas je suis un gros
geek une école d'ingé j'ai fait un
master d'intelligence artificielle à
l'université lille parce que tout ça ça
me fascine et et apprécier les faire une
thèse aux urgences artificielle à
l'université de maastricht en hollande
où il s'intéressait au jeu de go et je
suis allé là bas c'était une seule ombre
en europe où il intéressait le jeu
debout et je voulais faire les thèses
absolument faire un test vih pour situer
un peu ses 15 années c'est donc ces
instants où a progressé très vite et ça
c'était en 2005 et 2010
la tension ne goûte donc c'était
vraiment le moment où beaucoup de gens
pensaient que le jeu gosses ne serait
jamais résolue elle jamais de chant qui
arrive à battre des projets web la
grande majorité des chercheurs pour sexe
se serait pas possible et il y avait
quelques quelques personnes dont le
directeur est ce qu'il dit c'est non non
tu vas arriver faut persévérer
il roulait techniques ont pas mal évolué
entre la wii donc les techniques ont
radicalement changé donc à l'époque en
2005 qui utilisaient un peu les mêmes
techniques qu'aux échecs c'est à dire
qu'ils aient une fonction d'évaluations
pour pour évaluer la position du terrain
et il faisait de la recherche brut
jusqu'à arriver à évaluer la position
ça marche très bien aux échecs et pas du
tout au goût parce que nous on n'arrive
jamais à avoir une estimation convenable
de la situation du coup il fait il
fallait inventer d'autres techniques du
coup
on a essayé d'autres techniques et on
était vraiment les premiers à parmi les
premiers ces techniques innovantes et
voir comment on a fait cette transition
les techniques qu'on n'utilisait c'était
les techniques de monte carlo c'est à
dire qu'on allait faire des simulations
se doit les at war jusqu'à la fin de la
partie
donc ça paraissait un peu farfelues
comme idée puisque l'on se débat dans
ses parties aléatoire il va y avoir
beaucoup d'erreurs qui vont être faites
donc après ce qu'on va pouvoir malgré
toutes ces erreurs
sorti un signal c'était pas évident il y
avait beaucoup de chercheurs qui disait
il y en avait même un grand codeurs
d'échecs qui disait que les techniques
de monte carlo
c'était la bataille des singes ça
n'arrivera jamais à rien ouais parce que
voilà c'était c'était trop absurde on
pouvait pas créer quelque chose de
d'intelligent en partant de l'absurde
ouais alors qu'elle est technique de
monte carlo se retrouve au coeur d'un
des composants importants de chaque
tableau qui a battu lice idole c'est
parti assez connu et exactement et donc
quand on parle d'al tago les gens aiment
parler surtout du dip learning il ya
dedans mais en fait c'est deux grosses
algorithmes il ya le dip learning et le
monte carlo et l'époque le monte carlo
était encore très important dans cette
partie et en particulier ses lumières
comprendra godec les monte carlo est
particulièrement utilisé pour explorer
l'arbre savoir quelle qu'elle couvre
mieux explorer dans l'arbre des
possibilités si ça vous avez fait voilà
c'est en fait comment est-ce qu'on va
prendre tout ce bruit et en faire une
recherche
une recherche structuré et donc ce qui
était super intéressant c'est que du
coup on en fait tous les coups
importants étaient dans l'arbre et après
les coups aléatoire devenait sur sur des
coupes importantes donc en fait ça
changeait rien donc on arrivait
extraire de l'intelligence à partir de
quelque chose de stupide à la base lui
faisant essayer des millions et des
millions de choses
et du coup à la fin de ta tête tu t'es
dit c'est moi sont pour bientôt le jour
alors à la fin de match on a eu les
premières victoires contre des êtres
humains à 9 pierre donc ça c'est donc
c'est moi qui opérait le programme de
paris pendant que le programme joue à
los angeles était au milieu de l'année à
paris et voilà c'était la première
victoire contre un pro à 9 pierre de
handicap
ouais donc ça c'était ça c'était quelque
chose oui en fait s'est passé quelque
chose au début leproux a essayé de faire
une arnaque qui marchent normalement qui
marchait avec tous les programmes là
notre programme a été capable de voir
que son arnaque passait pas et après ça
je savais que la partie était de le que
c'était un type de partie que mon
programme savait gagner
et oui mais cantatrice à 99,9 pièce
d'handicap parce que tu pensais que ça
prendra du temps pour arriver à zéro je
me rendais compte que ouais on était
encore dans l'ennui il est passé déjà de
9 jusqu'à 6 on a aussi lu la première
victoire à saint pierre mais il y avait
encore énormément de boulot et c'est
avec le deep learning seulement des
années des années après c'est en ces
temps plus tard que qu'on est passé de 6
pierre 0 donc presque donc les parents
ils voient après ta thèse qu est ce que
tu avais donc après match aller bosser à
microsoft research à cambridge
sur un stage en angleterre et et après
je suis allé directement à los angeles
et au bureau de tu faisais quoi donc à
google gt gt mis sur un programme pour
le pour les recommandations de youtube
comment va prendre toutes les sessions
des utilisateurs et trouver qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on va leur recommander
il y avait fait elle pas bien mais aimer
tout le temps là bas alors il y avait
des trucs très bien j'étais avec des
gens super super intelligent super
motivé les conditions de travail étaient
rivés c'était à los angeles avec un très
bon salaire des locaux avec des baby
foots magie
donc ça c'était très chouette
le problème c'est que je me suis assez
vite rendu compte que la manière dont
les recommandations ont été programmés
en fait c'est enfermer les gens dans des
bulles filtrante en fait vrai ça ne peut
que renforcer la même chose leur montre
tout le temps la même chose et du coup
ça va avoir des gros effets pervers sur
sur la société et du coup je me suis dit
le tiens je vais pouvoir essayer je suis
fait google en fait on peut en théorie
passer 20 % de son temps à faire un
projet annexe pas ce que je vais faire
je vais faire mes projets annexes pour
essayer de montrer comment on peut faire
les choses différemment mais est enfermé
les utilisateurs en début de film et
leur permet de vraiment découvrir et de
s'enrichir youtube mais ça ça a été
perçu comme en bas en fait ça c'était
perçu donc j'ai proposé trois projets et
donc il est pas mal ça a été perçu
différemment par le management et par
les googleurs facile et pas mal de
googler qui était motivée par les idées
que j'avais donc sept personnes
différentes qui ont élevé au moins une
semaine pour créer des prototypes
ouais mais à chaque fois que j'allais
voir le management avec le prototype
fini c'était un peu la même réponse
était oui mais c'est pas vraiment le
focus de la boîte en ce moment là on est
en train de ouais ça c'est pas notre
coeur de métier quand c'est pas de faire
des trucs qui marchent différemment on
essaie de on a des objectifs de
rentabilité donc là c'était entendu en
fait le but de youtube c'était de
montrer le plus en plus de vidéos que
les gens passent de la télé à youtube
donc moi ce que je faisais c'était
n'essayez pas de maximiser le temps de
juger scellier moment d'apporter quelque
chose le plus à l'utilisateur
après j'essaie de le justifier en disant
oui mais si on lui permet de découvrir
des choses il va passer plus de temps
mais mais mais c'était pas directe et
donc j'en étais enfin les managers
n'était pas intéressé quand il est
google s'est essayé à d'autres
ingénieurs
oui des ingénieurs est ce que je pense
quelque chose dont on peut changer de
tenue alors nager oui j'ai vu directeur
des recommandations il ya
2 - truc comme ça et qui m'a dit oui
guillaume les choses ont bien changé
youtube qui est maintenant c'est plus ce
que c'était avant maintenant prend ces
problèmes les problèmes dont on a parlé
très sérieusement on a des équipes
dessus qui on maximise pas seulement le
watch time on maximise aussi la
responsabilité donc on ad'autres
métriques goodstein donc là dessus ils
reconnaissent que voilà juste voir
maximiser le watch times en fait ça va
avoir des effets pervers n'est donc ils
reconnaissent un peu que tout ce qu'ils
ont fait pendant des années c'était
c'était pas terrible mais voilà tant
qu'ils appellent donc il y avait pas de
pression l'extérieur google mais tant
que les gens se plaignaient pas
l'extérieur
google n'avait pas vraiment de raison de
changer
ouais enfin j'imagine que c'était
lorsque tu étais à google c'était vers
2012 2013 puissent quand tu vois là bas
ce n'est pas pour du tube était encore à
sept petits pas ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
du coup peut-être que c'était plus dur
de voir des effets à youtube était déjà
quand même assez énorme l'un en 2000
2010 n'était pas là j'étais pas au tout
début de youtube en deux matches 2000
2010 2011 2012
elle était déjà énorme et mais voilà en
plein en pleine croissance terry lui
trois phases dans youtube première phase
où il était tout petit inconnu la phase
où j'étais qui était vraiment la phase
de croissance qui est bon roule en un
truc génial mais il faut il faut juste
prendre le même concept à essayer de
réinventer le concept prend 2 le concept
est juste le faire grossir mais il a
maintenant un peu la phase de maturation
ou
là ils se rendent compte qu'ils peuvent
pas rester sur le même concept justement
des équipes sacrées des réels problèmes
il faut sa chance de faire ce qu'il en
soit c'est peut-être les intérêts ou un
peu changé parce que en phase de
croissance avait été utilisé avec
l'impression est en concurrence et que
vous postez plus important d'avoir eu
exactement
et bah maintenant elles sont toujours en
concurrence
oui avec facebook et avec avec la télé
il a vraiment différents profils
d'utilisateurs tels profils utilisateurs
qui va être tout temps sur youtube cette
heure qui va être tout le temps sur la
télé a c'est quelqu'un de la télé à
youtube pour eux c'est très important
que ces mêmes investissements sur le
très long terme
pas mal c'est une vision et elle n est
pas en train de gagner par rapport à
l'été pour autant ça je pense pas que
c'est encore ça augmente et à 30% par an
au moment où je sais pas où ils en sont
maintenant à jour et steven narod dit la
taille de youtube salar la taille du
cube c'est un milliard d'heures de vues
par jour
donc c'est monstrueux c'est à dire qu'il
ya 7 milliards 7 milliard d'êtres
humains yens 2 milliards de personnes
qui ont accès à youtube et sur 2
milliards de personnes
il ya un milliard d'eur c'est à dire que
chaque personne qui voit un tout petit
peu youtube un jour tu en entends tu
vois en moyenne y passe une demi heure
par jour sur youtube donc c'est
absolument démentielle donc là dessus
est évidemment lié la musique mais gens
qui utilisent youtube comme leurs
playlists mais quand même c'est
l'attraction de musique
je suis pas maintenant à un moment je
suis passé aux alentours de 50% pour
donner un gros ordre d'idée très
travaillé donc après voilà divisé par
deux si on veut ne publie pas la musique
je sais pas trop ce que c'est maintenant
et du coup quel point tu pourrais poser
à la librairie de recours nation youtube
alors en fait il ya pleins pleins
d'effets pervers mais qui dérivent tous
du même problème c'est à dire de design
donc ce problème a été mis en valeur par
un article de google dit mind qui publie
les en ont parlé sur twitter 1er mars et
qui montre comment ces algorithmes de
recommandations vont créer des bulles de
filtres des chambres d'écho passe quand
vous vous donne une recommandation
disons sur sur le foot
si vous aimez le football
ils ont cliqué du coup l'algorithme
d'ici là où il aime le foot je vais leur
montrer une vidéo de foot
si tu cliques et ben et en remettre une
et si tu cliques pas il n'a aucune idée
de ce que tu aimes
donc en fait le problème c'est quand ce
problème de signal y a pas de signal
pour dire fois les dans une autre
direction
c'est très difficile à faire donc
j'avais fait des prototypes pour comment
faire ça google ça c'est vraiment le sus
le sujet difficile mais qui aussi très
très touchy parce que si on fait si on
essaye de changer radicalement youtube
etc en business qui est moins rentable
ça peut être très dangereux pour pour
youtube donc
peu avant de sortir un autre notre
algorithme en fait il faut vraiment
qu'ils fassent beaucoup d'essais mais ce
que d'autres problèmes
donc en fait ce problème des bulles de
filtres en fait il est l'origine de
plein plein de gros problème donc pour
moi un cas vraiment vraiment marquant
c'est ces derniers mois y ait eu des
révélations sur des vidéos pédophiles
c'est à dire des fêtes c'était juste des
vidéos où on verrait la vidéo on tient à
l'épaté d'office c'est juste des petites
filles dans des positions bizarres à la
piscine est en fait les gens de youtube
heures qui sont rendus court que cette
vidéo était promu massivement par
l'algorithme à partir de plein d'autres
vidéos et que du coup quand on cliquait
sur une de ses vidéos l'algorithme aller
nous recommander d'autres vidéos de
petite fille dans la zone de fitness et
c est là qu est ce qui s'est passé dans
cette ce qui se passait c'est que du
coup il y avait une petite masse de
pédophilie sûr sur youtube mais qui
passent des heures et des heures à
regarder ce genre de vidéos - et du coup
comme il passe plus de temps à regarder
ce genre de vidéos ce genre de vidéos à
des meilleures stats pour l'algorithme
donc du coup l'algorithme essaye de dire
comme on n'est plus donc le but de
l'algorithme est la base c'est juste de
maximiser le temps de vue mais si les
pédophiles passe plus de temps que les
autres sur youtube le but de
l'algorithme ça va être de créer plus de
pédophiles
donc on a la meilleure intelligence
artificielle du monde qui était en train
de maximiser le nom de pédophiles
donc c'est complètement
on a vu ça plein d'autres trucs et des
trucs un peu zoophiles aussi ou des
vidéos de chevaux en fait
et quand tu cherchais une vidéo de
cheval à une époque
en fait tu voyais toujours des vidéos il
y avait un truc qui est en fait il est
mais pourquoi celle là est en fait
restée exactement le même idée parce
qu'on peut dire qu'on veut un peu sur
tout sujet où il ya des personnes qui
sont qui sont prêtes à voir beaucoup de
vidéos de semaine
style les lois et on peut se dire bon
bah ce genre de suez peut être addictif
et que si on pense à vous montrer
quelques unes de ces vidéos à ces gens
là peut-être qu'ils vont vouloir
regarder ces civils du coup il va
vraiment la recommander maximum de
journée donc il ya des vidéos par
exemple avec les théories du complot
c'est exactement ça qui se passe donc
j'ai montré comment les vidéos de
théorie lui le terreau pattes par
exemple étaient recommandés massivement
par l'algorithme à partir de n'importe
quoi ouais pour essayer de d'appâter les
gens vers l'avant mais il y avait un
article 3 que c'était le daily beast qui
avait montré comment une nana qui était
tombé dans la théorie de la terre plate
ça c'est dit
quand j'ai découvert deux théories de la
terre plate j'ai passé trois jours je
dormais même plus j'étais complètement
fasciné imaginez-vous maintenant dans la
tête de l'algorithme c'est l'agglo dit
c'est jackpot
ouais ben salem dix mois passés quelques
vidéos parfois dans une refondation et
emilie non mais ça c'est pas un truc qui
m'intéresse a pris mais je me dis si je
clique dessus ça se trouve c'est qu'il
faut en parler ni intéressé est passé en
scène des heures dessus qui est
dangereux est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
problèmes fait conséquence de ces
voiliers afin donc théorie du complot
les trucs un peu bizarres et les trucs
et ne fait là la haine et ultra efficace
pour créer si vous êtes super vénère
contre quelque chose l'une des réactions
c'est de vraiment attentif parce que si
on est dans une situation de combat le
fight or flight
ça rend les gens vraiment attentif allié
qu'à voir le xxème siècle pour voir que
la haine et efficace pour créer de
l'engagement et du coup sur youtube
du coup l'algorithme que j'ai été
programmée je les ai vus dans plein de
cas essayez de de promouvoir ces vidéos
de peur et de haine parce qu'elles sont
justes efficaces pour tendu donc les
produits de l'algorithme c'est logique
du point de vue de la société c'est
absurde c'est que la colère soit si
généralisée sur un site viral on compte
donc tout ça tu ne possèdes tu t'en
rendu compte un peu lorsque tu étais à
google donc à google en fait j'ai essayé
de voir
je voulais surtout pas regarder des
détails de l gorrite
je voulais surtout pas prendre un
exemple regardez on m'a recommandé c'est
assez mal non je voulais rester sur le
plan théorique voilà sur d un système de
recommandations qui prend ça comme une
poutre qui fait ça ça va avoir un tel
effet guilbaud et donc ça restait un peu
très théorique donc je pense que les
gens comprenaient pas pourquoi j'étais
aussi je pense que mon bois se
comprenait pas pourquoi j'étais aussi
remonté comme ça que c'est pourquoi
c'était aussi important pour moi de
trouver des alternatives et du coup dont
l'état est acquitté google pour sa en
2013 ouais donc bah en fait c'est
en fait j'ai fait un moment mon boss m'a
dit bon guillaume ta performance là il
faut que t'arrêtes enfin mais je lui ai
parlé de d'une nouvelle idée pour
changer ça il me dit non et si j'étais
toi je ferais pas ça il donc pendant six
mois je me suis libre où j'arrête les
20% et tout et puis après au bout de six
mois je me suis dit bon ton pays c'est
trop important mais refaire ça puis 6,6
milliards il vire et j'ai été viré ok tu
appartiens à trouver le temps du support
dans les autres beaux muller j'ai trouvé
des supports dans des premiers temps
c'est à dire que voilà et plein de gens
pour pour aider sur ses projets mais une
fois que ben voilà les managers disais
non c'est pas mon responsability veux
pas qu'on paie plus la responsabilité
voilà sur beaucoup des problèmes dont
j'ai parlé par exemple les théories du
complot j'en parlais pas l'époque mais
ça je me suis rendu compte quand j'écris
aligot transparente si justement à quel
point ces théories du complot était de
dire comme on est donc là je suis allé
voir des amis google en disant regardez
le nom de théorie du complot pouvoir
commander et à chaque fois c'était la
bonne réponse est à dire oui ça n'a pas
terrible mais en même temps c'est pas de
ma faute tu as si les utilisateurs ils
aiment regarder des trucs comme ça c'est
pas notre dame de toute sa clique sur
sur des trucs aussi des huiles
c'est pas de notre faute si
l'utilisateur
cliquer sur des trucs et ne j'aimerais
bien changer les gens mais voilà les
gens sont comme ça donc essayé de
pousser la responsabilité sur une seule
utilisateurs comme c'est un gros truc en
passion de ne pas être responsable quand
même du mali ne sont pas forcément
responsable de l'algorithme youtube ou
plus assister à ça donc personne se sent
responsable donc on a une machine bien
huilée où tout le monde pousse la
responsabilité sur d'autres quelqu'un
d'autre soit youtube soit sur le de
l'utilisateur et du coup les gens voient
les problèmes et laisse passer et passe
à autre chose derrière
arrête de regarder les problèmes ouais
il qu'après avoir partie de google
qu'est ce que tu as fait alors quand je
suis partie google j'ai fait une start
up c'est bon je voulais vous montrer que
ses avions avec marché en mode start up
ouais mais ce n'était pas la bonne
manière parce que moi j'ai essayé en
fait de résoudre un problème qui était
avec l'algorithme de youtube et
d'essayer de le faire start up
j'avais fait un site de e-commerce en
fait un site de e-commerce
ce qui est difficile c'est pas parce
qu'il crucial c'est pas tellement un
algorithme sait se faire connaître
créer une marque reconnue et donc voit
qu'il faut que ça sur un algorithme ça
n'a pas marché et après j'ai fait du
consulting et shelly bosser pour une
assos qui faisait du 10 recommandations
pour les chômeurs pour les aider à
trouver des milliards de boulot longueur
avec du big data
ok
je travaille et non pour cet assaut est
à lui et à trèbes 1 l'an dernier j'ai
surtout de passer beaucoup de temps à
parler parler de ces problèmes
c'est sûr il vaut transparente si là
j'étais à l'université paris-est et mode
il est donc tu peux parler un peu [ __ ]
de transparence et donc à hugo
transparence si le but c'est de se dire
bon youtube on sait pas ce qui s'y passe
je vais voir ce que l'algorithme vers
quoi l'algorithme nous pousse si on
reste longtemps sur youtube
vers quoi l algorithme va nulle part de
recherche et je suis les recommandations
pour voir ce que va nous emmener
et voilà c'est là que je me suis rendu
compte que tu entends talent il y avait
des billets politique dans un temps il
est des billets à la théorie du complot
il y avait des billets vers la haine des
billets vers des vidéos un peu bizarre
enfin voilà à quel point est ce que
pensent les gens de youtube en sont
conscients de ça je pense que voilà les
gens de youtube
ils veulent pas une expression qui se
disent tout le temps c'est on veut pas
être ceux qui décident ce qui est vrai
ou ce qui est pas vrai mais en fait
c'est eux qui décident si ce qui a
commandé ce qui n'est pas recommandé
donc s'ils veulent pas décider ce qui
est vrai ou pas vrai au final ils
recommandent énorme et montrent qu'ils
sont faux quoi c'est juste une excuse
pour recommander énormément de choses
qui sont fausses donc les gens et
youtube
voilà les 101 c'est des gens que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui sont dans un système
dans un système où ils peuvent pas ils
regardent même pas les problèmes parce
que ils veulent pas se remettre en cause
c'est un peu comme une grosse
administration quoi je n'arrive pas à
résoudre les problèmes parce que c'est
trop d'administration trop de couches de
hiérarchie qui parce que en fait l'ailé
gauche de youtube est vraiment enfin de
toute façon il va faire une
recommandation la convention on peut pas
l'enlever composant important de youtube
et du coup de toute façon à faire de la
fondation met du groupe en ces cas
neutralité ou qu'il n'ya pas d'arbitrage
via cette recommandation c'est et puis
le penser comme ça c'est sans doute une
façon de se justifier de diffuser la
traçabilité en quoi c'est ça c'est en
fait c'est très délicat parce que s'ils
commencent à admettre qu'ils ont de la
responsabilité dans les recommandations
légalement les mais ils prennent illégal
illégalement ils vont ils vont avoir de
la responsabilité
donc en fait je pense qu'ils essayent de
pousser le plus possible le moment où
les gens vont se rend compte qu'en fait
ils sont responsables de ce qu'ils font
ouais ouais et est venu donc du polygone
idealg aux transports si c'est un peu
aussi insisté sur le fait qu'il ya
vraiment spécialité un prêt important
voilà que lily a un impact donc après
comment comment gérer cette
responsabilité c'est quelque chose de
complètement nouveau et évidemment on va
parvenir à un modèle ou d'algorithmes
c'est toujours quelqu'un qui est
responsable du contenu mais en ôtant le
modèle de responsabilité qu'il était
c'est pour la presse qui marche très
bien pour la presse est complètement
cassé et a créé ces problèmes de
théories du complot de de haine et c'est
qu'on voit maintenant que si vous avez
des politiciens qui sont extrêmement
hargneux qui mentent et sait c'est
qu'ils utilisent les bonnes pratiques de
youtube c'est pas c'est pas de la faute
des politiciens si les réseaux sociaux
amplifie plus les mensonges que la
vérité bah en fait si vous passez sur la
vérité un peu comme ce que nous certifie
tomber celle de faire vous tirez une
balle de roupies soit on fait souvent la
remarque fois de plus je pense que nos
marques un peu naïve mais d'essayer de
voir retirer tout algorithmes et tout ça
mais il faut bien dire que va pour qu'on
achète on va chercher une vidéo sur
youtube soit youtube pour une rotonde et
aléatoirement des vidéos sur youtube
mais bill aux prises au hasard sur
youtube probablement c'est pas une vidéo
très très très fiable et puis quoi qu'il
arrive souvent les gens vont chercher
quelque part il faut faire de recharge
sur blocs sur youtube et du couvent à
youtube va être me devoir proposer des
vidéos en faisant en quelque part il y
aura toujours un peu de recommandations
de l de rythme ça paraît illusoire
d'essayer de s'en séparer
oui donc c'est pas un peu comme on
assume c'est beaucoup le cul de 70% des
vues sur youtube sont à la suite des
recommandations donc c'est elle quand
elle de recommandations faites c'est une
partie majeure de youtube et donc will
you tube absolument pas ni revue de se
séparer l'algorithmie envie d'être
responsables pour ce que recommande
algorithmes mais moi ce que je dis c'est
que quand le youtube recommande une
vidéo plus d'un milliard de fois
ouais enfin certaines vidéos étaient
recommandés des milliards de fois
certaines vidéos quand ils recommandent
une vidéo un milliard de fois c'est pas
possible de dire que youtube a pas de
responsabilité
donc il n'a pas après c'est à partir de
combien de fois et après quand tu me
recommander une vidéo fait pas mille
fois dix mille fois cent mille fois on
sait pas c'est pas très grave mais quand
ils ont recommandé une vidéo plus d'un
plusieurs millions de fois là il
faudrait commencer à se dire qu'il
devrait y avoir une responsabilité et le
problème c'est que c'est pas clair de se
dire à quel moment il faut que la
responsabilité comment cette
responsabilité a peut-être le signe des
difficultés sera pas ça c'est moi je
pensais à ces problèmes c'est que c'est
des problèmes assez assez inédit c'est
assez nouveau
bien sûr alors ouais pour pouvoir
retourner à big picture en fait on est
au moment de l'humanité où on devient on
fait des machines qui sont plus
intelligentes que nous sur certains sur
certains domaines qui sont plus capables
de raisonner de calculer que nous qu'ils
sont meilleurs que nous pour trouver la
meilleure vidéo
mais entre pour maximiser le temps du
donc en fait il ya eu la révolution
industrielle
cent cinquante ans
la première phase et des machines qui
était qu'ils étaient plus fortes que
nous aidons les a complètement
transformé la société parce que
mécaniquement on arrivait à faire des
machines plus forte que nous plus forte
que les chevaux mais ça a révolutionné
la société maintenant on arrive à faire
des intelligences artificielles plus
intelligente que donc c'est un moment de
l'humanité extrêmement crucial et au
lieu de se poser la question comme ça
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour que
ça se passe bien pour que l'humain se
retrouvent pas dépasser écrasé par par
la machine
non en fait on a des gens qui sont dans
leur vision de tendue et maximiser le
temps du à tout prix ces questions et
avait très que son tour fou à dire c'est
que l'algorithme de youtube a vu toutes
les vidéos youtube ici les copyrights
autre est passé on voit le nombre de
vidéos sur youtube je suis passé comme
en vidéo sur un crac de se dire ça quoi
forcément elle a accès à plein donné l
année zeppelin donné ok on n'aura jamais
accès donc non seulement ils ont
structuré toutes les données c'est à
dire qu'ils ont vu les vidéos
catégoriser donc après avec le deep
learning vous pouvez extraire les
éléments donc ils savent combien il ya
de personnes dans la vidéo
qu'est ce qui s'y passe quels sont les
thèmes il fut titre à l'automatisme
titrage automatique etc
tout ça c'est un truc hallucinant il ya
un autre truc et lucie encore plus
hallucinant ce tour c'est que le savent
exactement pour chaque personne dans le
monde combien seconde ils ont passé sur
exactement toutes les vidéos vidéos par
vidéo et du coup tout ça c'est garder
dans leur historique et donc même si
vous avez été dans les théories du
complot ou donner des trucs qui ne
jouent dans n'importe quoi l'algorithme
va s'en souvenir dans 10 ans et ça va
encore que vous avez été là tu pourquoi
fins elle c'est un peu un incroyable
c'est pour ça que moi comme moteur de
recherche l'utilisent pas plus google
parce que le fait d'avoir toutes ces
requêtes qu'ils soient stockés pendant
toute la vie en fait c'est pas logique
c'est assez énorme et on fait tout pour
en inférer énormément de dunes d'un
individu juste avec son histoire et
youtube
on s'est tous ses centres d'intérêt voir
à quelle heure ils soulèvent qu'elle
arrive un jour
c'est incroyable on se rend pas compte
que ce soit avec les recherches google
je savais qu les recherches google avec
l arrivée des recherches google ans
après un ou deux ans à voir son rythme
de vie précis et romane en tête ont
passé avec qu'est ce qui peut être fait
du coup ouais alors ce qui peut être
fait en fait ce que je me suis rendu
compte c'est que ce qui peut être fait y
est un délai tonnes de trucs qui peuvent
être faits et expérimentée mais voilà
que youtube je pensais que google
c'était une boîte qui quittent et
innovante qui essayait de tester plein
de trucs et je me suis rendu compte
on me semble danser que en fait cette
innovation c'était bon pour l'image
d'avoir cette image d'innovation donc
fait ce qu'ils faisaient vraiment du
chiffre c'était 2 à d'essayer de créer
des nouveaux trucs à partir de zéro
c'était juste de brosser un peu la poule
aux oeufs d'or 2 3 poule aux oeufs d'or
ce matin google qui est une poule aux
oeufs d'or
tu as you tube qui n'osent d'or sur le
sultan de vue et du coup il essaye de la
faire pour le plus quoi faire quelle
qu'elle soit bien fondé micro réglages
tout le temps des tonnes de micron
réglages pour montrer sur trois pixels
met trois pixels de plus 3 pixels de
moins tout est ultra testé pour que les
gens restent un tout petit peu plus
c'est un peu ce qu'ils font ne sont pas
du tout dans l'innovation les six mois
quand je suis arrivé avec ses idées
innovantes à l'intérieur d'eux avait un
mec lui le but c'était de faire le plus
de brevets par an lui essayé de faire un
maximum de vous m'avez pourquoi parce
qu'un regret c'est lui rapporter à 4000
dollars
google payer 4000 $ je crois qu'ils ont
laissé maintenant les prix parce que ce
genre d'abus si vous faisiez un brevet
avec google savait 4000 dehors parce que
google voulait avoir un maximum de
beauvais pour se faire attaquer par
d'autres grosses boîtes
donc du coup il essayait de breveter
tout et n'importe quoi donc ils
connaissaient bien tout ce qui avait été
breveté il donc il prenait une idée
alors si on met un bouton en dessous
d'une vidéo pour revenir
3 venus aux précédentes l envers c'est
un concept
lisez c'est donc ça il bossait avec des
juristes pour savoir qu'est ce qui était
brevetables et il décide de breveter un
maximum mais du coup les centaines de
milliers des brevetés tout et n'importe
quoi
et donc quand un homme est comme ça qu
donc connaissez les normes et ont tout
ce qui est l innovation
j'arrive et je lui ai montré lundi
c'est tellement simple et efficace que
si ça existait déjà serait déjà été fait
et donc s'ils n'aiment pas la peine
d'essayer
donc l'idée c'est que ben si quelqu'un
le fait à l'extérieur de google et que
les démarches d'un de deux choses l'une
soit il rachète la boîte soit si la
boîte veut pas se laisser racheter ils
copient l'idée quoi donc c'est ce qui
s'est passé blue pour cette idée précise
que je l'avais parlait en fait cette
idée a été développée plus tard par
clint reste donc indépendamment
ils ont rappelé à pine thérèse guided
search 7 l'idc vous faites une recherche
est en dessous il vous met des tags pour
essayer de préciser la recherche donc
c'est exactement ce que j'avais proposé
à google il qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec google google à copier ça et
maintenant si vous allez sur google
images et que vous faites une recherche
il va vous mettre détails pour préciser
la recherche
ce qui est incroyable c'est que cette
même idée en fait elle marche très très
bien avec google search elle marche très
très bien avec youtube google aurait pu
le mettre sur youtube ce serait génial
une horizon juste copié collé ce que ce
que les autres parce qu'elle rit avec
une terrasse qui faisait ça donc il
fallait pas qu'ils sont en retard sur
ping terrestre qu'ils ont copié sur
google images mais c'est tout pas sur
les autres produits voilà donc ça c'est
pour donner une idée de la mentalité de
google qui pas du tout nos sociétés
innovantes comment comment croire parce
que c'est devenu trop gros pour eux
c'est une grosse boîte qui ont des ils
ont des objectifs par rapport à leurs
actionnaires et essayer de maximiser
leurs objectifs par l'enjeu pour leurs
actionnaires et innover en fait ça prend
énormément de temps et au prix où ils
payent les ingénieurs si les ingénieurs
passe du temps à innover ça coûte
beaucoup trop cher ça ouais algériens
dont on sait à quel point ce que youtube
et google sont c'est la même chose ans
et il n'y a pas de rang il n'y a pas de
frontières donc c'est à dire que ça fait
les locaux de youtube qui horrifie sur
un peu plus loin qu'ils étaient sombres
nous alors que google était inventée
liviu la presse et les bonnes personnes
et des bureaux de youtube
dans les locaux de google
je n'y a pas trop google dans les bureau
régional de youtube parce qu'ils sont
pas si gros que ça mais voilà c'est
vraiment la même boîte me donne tout est
intégré
c'est vraiment une distinction de
prendre appui sont très très plaisant
parce qu'il ya des google qui qui
maîtrisent toutes les recherches
il ya eu tube qui maîtrisent une énorme
partie du temps de vue donc sont très
complémentaires ou lui a fait beaucoup
plus d'argent mais youtube gèrent
beaucoup plus d'informations à que les
gens voient leur parole mais tu l'as
plus de pouvoir aux commandes passées et
puis j'ai vu aujourd'hui sur une route
sur youtube de recherche sur google il
est peut-être plus de pouvoir
d'influencé politique par exemple
violence sociétale
est ce que parce que oui google
il va te donner que ce que tu recherches
mais youtube va commander d'autres trucs
donc il va te pousser dans une certaine
direction et y'a pas de mal en soi ce
que youtube pousse les gens dans la
direction à kelly veulent moi ce que je
combats c'est que je veux savoir dans
quelle direction les pousse les gens
veulent que les gens soient capables de
partir de youtube s'il estime que la
direction dans laquelle youtube google
les pouces n'est pas une bonne direction
ce que tu penses que youtube devra
recommander davantage la vidéo duke
hâtive d'esprit critique aiguisé son
algorithme pour converser donc du tube a
mis en avant pas mal de vidéos
éducatives donc il ya c'est un paradoxe
complet c'est à dire que l'algorithme
lui-même en maximisant tendue des vidéos
éducatives ont aucune chance de
rivaliser
tm global avec les théories du complot
qui sont plus fascinant en fait si tu
fais une vidéo educated en fait tu te
restreint la réalité on essayait de
faire du wat stein sens restreint à la
réalité et où tu peux inventer n'importe
quoi faire de la fiction
en fait aucune chance de gagner est donc
ils ont un algorithme qui par design va
complètement défavorisés après ils ont
essayé plein de trucs ça va essayer de
mettre en avant plein de youtube heures
un scientifique et où pour pallier ces
problèmes et c'était après y'a ils ont
dit mais quand même quand même c'est dur
pour les créateurs scientifique donc il
y avait mes racines homme qui avait fait
une super vidéo là dessus pour expliquer
comment au début les créateurs
scientifiques ont bien exploser et à un
moment sont un peu craché donc je pense
que le moment où ils sont crashés ses
comptes youtube à un peu boosté sur le
surtemps de vue du coup forcément là les
trucs scientifiques vont s'écraser
du coup il disait à quel point lui lever
une fatigue de devoir faire du clic beit
de devoir
trouver des titres et des annonces de
devoir complètement changer le type de
contenu qui fait en fonction de ce que
ça va faire cliquer les gens ou pas
parce que les voilà il ya deux social le
clic qui est encore très important donc
le clip bakel avoir une faute au québec
et après combien de temps les gens
restent sur la liste c'est intéressant
c'était bien parce que ça montre aussi
que la gouaille de youtube directement
ils recommandent il a fait quoi les gens
sont exposés mais indirectement aussi
motive les créateurs de contenu à aller
dans certaines réactions plutôt plein
d'autres cette vidéo devait ratisse y
sommes il était vraiment conscient que
voilà lui ce qu'il essayait de me suivre
c'était pas vraiment les utilisateurs
s'étaient pas vraiment les visionner
youtube c'est l algorithme way d'essayer
de rivère s'imaginer les wallons elle
veut transparent si c'est aussi utile
pour les pour les créateurs de vidéos
parce que du coup tu vois qu'elles sont
les vidéos qui sont recommandés le plus
par l'algorithme loup pour les les gens
qui veulent comprendre l'algorithme pour
les créateurs c'est aussi noté la
semaine passée avec d'autres personnes
pour aller aux transports
ouais donc il ya pas mal de joueurs qui
vont aider donc moi j'étais le coeur
après il y avait pas mal de gens qui
vont l'aider sur dix est d'accord le
programmation etc
et du coup là se fait des gens ça ça
fait deux ans elle existe est alors
faire un bilan après deux ans alors
maintenant
oui il ya une lutte d'un pack c'est à
dire que youtube a changé beaucoup de
choses aux suite des révélations qu'on a
fait sur l eau transparente si l'an
dernier ce qui le premier la première
chose qu'ils ont changé c'est qu'ils ont
des slips est en dessous des théories du
complot des slips et wikipedia mais ce
qui était un peu une décision un peu
bizarre mais était de dire pourquoi on
dit que la terre est plate
on va vous mettre un petit slip est pour
vous dire et les routes en watts qui me
c'est pourquoi mettre des slips et
wikipedia seulement sur certains types
de vidéos
je veux dire je trouve pas que c'est une
mauvaise idée de me dessiner patrick
veut dire mais il faudra y mettre sur
toutes les vidéos corée est redirigé
vers l'article wikipédia pour tous et
tous les sujets et je trouve ça un peu
bizarre qui les fait que pour les vidéos
sur des sujets débattus à savoir
semaines on parle notre honneur pour cet
hiver je trouve ça fou que ça existe
mais qui paient moi je me rappelle la
première fois que j'ai entendu parler de
wikipédia je dis ça marchera jamais tout
le monde peut éditer
ça va être dominée par les trolls ouais
ils ceux qui disent n'importe quoi et en
fait paradoxalement nous ils ont trouvé
des très bons mécanismes pour bon il ya
des problèmes sur wikipédia mais grosso
modo quand même ça marche pas si mal que
ça ouais alors que ben on voit mon
twitter
il ya certaines parties twitter qui sont
complètement dominé par les trolls et
sertie de youtube aussi cherchent une
information fiable choisir voie bitumée
utile qu'il n'ya pas à chercher sur
google ou intel google renvoie aux
équipes et dior je vais pas parler de
talent ce qui fait dire c'est un peu le
l'endroit sur internet par ja il ya
quelques endroits comme ça matteau
raffoux stack overflow mais quelques
euros sur internet vous y rendre la
qualité mais oui parce que les
algorithmes qu'on va sur sur wikipédia
les sur stack overflow son design pour
ça c'est à dire qu'il y ait des systèmes
de riz ward sur sept et cover flow tu as
des systèmes de cuincy les autres est la
réponse est acquis qui poussent vers qui
pousse vers la vérité sur sur wikipédia
appareils et des systèmes de pour
enlever les trusts à dire c'est
quelqu'un troll une page en fait suite
quelqu'un qui clique
retour à la page avant pour que tout le
trolling soient effacées donc c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de troller que
dedans titre all est sûr sur youtube
c'est l'inversé beaucoup plus facile de
trouver ce qu'ils pensent que youtube
peut trouver des inspirations ses il
aurait plus de vingt sept et dix ans
qu'ils auraient pu trouver d inspiration
dans stack overflow cours à wikipedia
interest avec l'ordinateur mais c'est
donc en fait il il peut faire plein de
trucs mais la question c'est est-ce
qu'ils veulent le faire ici ça diminue
le temps de vue
voilà pour hausser d'un choix parce
qu'ils sont toujours dans leur
compétition avec la télévision donc du
coup en fait ils vont faire le minimum
de choses pour que les gens arrêtent de
se plaindre de youtube et qu' ils
gardent leur temps donc c'est un peu ce
qu'ils ont fait avec leslie page
wikipédia qui qui adopte peu les gens
peut-être ne sais pas mais et les kids
de côté ou a pas trop changé le temps de
lui un autre truc qu'ils ont fait cette
année qui est une réponse à ce que je
disais c'est ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
arrêter de promouvoir les théories du
complot les saints qui sont clairement
[Musique]
fausse et destructrices comme la théorie
de la terre plate ou très bien que c'est
mais il donc ils ont dit bon ben voilà
là on va arrêter de leur faire de la pub
c'est là qu'ils vont laisser la télé
la vidéo sur youtube super important
pour la liberté d'expression
ouais je trouve que ce que je sais pas
du tout qu'on enlève n'ai plus le droit
de dire quelque chose mais que ce soit
pas un algorithme qui décide ce qui est
la vérité ce qui doit être commandé à
tout le monde parce que l'algorithme et
s'en fout de ce qui est bon pour
l'humanité il s'en fout de la vérité
s'en fout de plein de valeurs humaines
très importante
ouais bah tu ne pense pas qu'on parlait
on connaît un peu plus ses valeurs
humaines aussi dans la grèce à ça c'est
mon excellent notre montrer comment on
peut faire ça montrer comment on peut
faire ça d'une manière
baky efficace tout ça pour être trop
faut regarder les performances en partie
- mais il faut aussi être beaucoup plus
bénéfique
pour les utilisateurs et pour l'humanité
va nous la loi de la manière dont on
marche les êtres humains c'est ça c'est
l'on se fixe des valeurs on se dit que
la liberté d'expression c'est bien on se
dit que voilà le on n'a pas le droit de
tuer les autres le droit ça de toutes
ses valeurs de liberté en fait c'est ce
qui a permis de modèle de société dans
lequel on vit et le problème c'est que
ces valeurs n'ont pas du tout été codé
dans un crime de youtube et du coup ça a
créé l'effet boule de neige ou ceux qui
ceux qui adhèrent pas aux valeurs de la
société dans ma main nue ont dû beaucoup
qui sont partis sur youtube du coup ils
ont poussé youtube dans cette direction
bon en fait ce qui est pour certaines
valeurs ce qui est ce qui peut-être bien
sûr il ya peut-être des moments où les
médias voulaient pas parler de choses là
sur youtube les gens pu en parler donc
ça c'est génial mais après si ça devient
extrême inverse si l'algorithme part
dans l'extrême inverse
là c'est la catastrophe parce que du
coup si on fait des belles valeurs
une société avec des valeurs morales
l'algorithme va par design favorisé les
valeurs inverse
mais de cette société là sur la liberté
que du coup c'est devenu qu'on a parlé
du tibet a semblé penser c'est que fais
tu récupères n'y a pas trop de liberté
d'expression dans un troll va être tu es
tellement c'est à dire que c'est un
troll tu vois il veut dire quelque chose
donc ils vont aller faire la pêche de
discussions vont dire non il ya ça aussi
font parler de cette manière et puis
après ils vont discuter sur comment
trouver de manière qui est libre et en
général ça va être
certaines personnes disent que blabla on
dit que sur tel machin la bible a
cueilli levons pas dire c'est la vérité
et c'est faux c'est vrai dire machin on
dit que c'est comme ça qu il ya plein de
mouvements sur wikipédia où il ya des
trolls ouais mais pas ceux qui sont
présentés en tant que prof donc moi par
exemple sur la théorie de la terre place
sur youtube ça ne dérange pas du tout
qu'il est vieillot terre plate mais le
fait qu'elles soient montrées à des gens
qui n'ont aucune idée dur pour essayer
de leur faire croire à ça vraiment au
lieu d'être montrées genre ces vidéos
regardées il ya des platines c'est
vraiment trop drôle
dans la théorie de la terre plate est
vraiment marrante regardez là c'est
vraiment deux contextes très différents
ouais c'est peut-être un petit peu
différent parce que du coup sûr équipé
diana c'est pas les discussions sur
lequel finalement on peut intervenir va
y avoir des discussions on a vraiment
une liberté d'expression en ce moment là
mais il ya quand même un filtre sur ce
qui est vraiment explosé lorsque les
gens donc sur la page de base un verre
d'eau et même sur la plus sûre la
plupart des pages en fait tu peux éviter
20 sites éditeurs disant machin tu as 2
je respecte les guidelines de wikipédia
tu vas pas être enlever quoi tu as être
avec eux si tu sais tu dis n'importe
quoi sans respecter son inspectrice a
donc après sur certains sujets très très
sensible les pages sont verrouillés pour
que et après du coup il ya un système de
sa remontée il ya des gens qui décident
at il donc du coup ces langues
ils ont plus de poids sur ce qui se
passe sur wikipédia est donc le problème
c'est les voix si on voulait faire ça
sur rue enfin sur youtube mais c'est
déjà ce qui se passe sur youtube c'est à
dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont plus de
poids que les autres
si vous passez plus comme ils favorisent
le temps de jeu si vous passez plus de
temps sur youtube vous allez avoir plus
de poids sur dell correct quelqu'un qui
passe moins de temps c'est ouais mais
après les personnes qui gagnent ce
pouvoir sur youtube d'abonnés sur
youtube n'ont pas été non pas eu cette
place de la même façon que quelqu'un qui
vient militaire important de wikipédia
accède à cette position
si je garde le pouvoir d'achat très
influent c'est parce qu'il a produit
beaucoup de contenu donc mais cet
horaire flower peu un mix entre les deux
ouais je sais y ait des ailiers les
admins quand même je crois sur stack
overflow du coup et c'est à elle c'est
pas évident de trouver le bon modèle
mais ce qui est important voir avec
youtube c'est que il n'essaye même pas
de trouver le bon modèle dire ils se
disent là on essaie de maximiser le
temps vu le but c'est pas de trouver le
modèle pour voir qu'est ce qui est bon
pour la société qu'est ce qui est vrai
qu est-ce qui est pas vrai et du coup de
temps en temps ça part en vrille temps
en temps si c'est génial temps en temps
les vidéos qui sont 80 ans et les vidéos
catastrophique mais les vidéos
catastrophique vous les verrez jamais
vous vous avez toujours l'impression que
youtube est génial parce que vous
regardez les vidéos qui vous intéressent
tout le monde pense que youtube est
fantastique mais ça sert à un élan piège
de la personnalisation d'information
c'est que on a l'impression que l'on
connaît youtube parce qu on interagit
avec lit double ou ce contexte on
intervient avec une autre youtube d'une
certaine manière c'est youtube est
beaucoup plus complexe
exactement ce que j'essaye de montrer
avec ouais ouais
du coup je travaille encore je parle de
transparence et ouais donc ce travail
encore là je suis en train de regarder
ce qui se passe pour
et les manifestations à hong kong
visiblement la youtube annoncé hier
qu'ils avaient enlevé 200 chaînes de
désinformation du gouvernement chinois
j'ai vu des associations gays sur
twitter qui m'a qui disait à quel point
quand on cherche une information sur sur
youtube sur les manifestations donc sur
la propagande chinoise et donc c'est
assez inquiétant mais pourquoi pourquoi
ce qui se passe at massey simplement que
la chaîne officielle chinoise est très
très forte optimisé youtube ils ont près
d'un milliard de vues ça fait des années
qu'ils utilisent youtube ils sont bien
meilleurs à utiliser youtube que les
protestants que ceux qui désirent équipe
pourquoi en maximiser donc ils ont des
aidants équipe donc du coup je sais pas
que youtube veut favoriser le
gouvernement chinois mais c'est que
naturellement l'équipe des forces et
ouais et en faveur du groupe harman est
en fait une pub et un et accable voilà
c'est ça parce que l'algorithme une fois
que tu es tu as compris comment les
marchés trouvent les bons trucs à dire
tu trouves les bonnes vidéos l'étude met
sur la bonne chaîne et c'est donc en
fait lui sa femme et s'est du coup très
difficile de lui parce que je me fous
qui se conçoivent des systèmes qu'ils ne
puissent pas être hacké par des
utilisateurs ma verrons alors si tu fais
un système qui vraiment peut pas être
hacké par un utilisateur malveillant ça
va être vraiment il faut être vraiment
conseil conservative plein de tests pour
vérifier que la personne est vraiment
qui elle est facebook c'est ça c'est à
dire que facebook libre il faut que vous
soyez qui vous dit on peut vous demander
votre photo d'identité vous présidente
ici s'il ya un doute donc
c'est ça youtube a décidé de pas faire
ça du tout mais dans certains cas sacré
sur un problème donc twitter et facebook
sont les premiers à réagir contiennent
les opérations d information moi c'est
la première fois que je vois youtube
réagir de manière publique et dire voilà
il ya eu une opération d information et
on a réagi de telle manière alors que
twitter et facebook ça fait très
longtemps qu'ils font ça parce que
j'étais en retard ah oui là est
clairement parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
jusqu'à présent il y avait eu la
pression médiatique sur facebook ou
twitter
donc après la pression médiatique
facebook et twitter ont changé leur mode
de fonctionnement et ouais parler
beaucoup plus de ces opérations de
désinformation et là maintenant qu'il
ait de la pression sur youtube youtube
comment sa réélection de smart
révélations sur les droits mais trois et
ils sont facebook et twitter il ya eu
des gens qu'ils interviewaient de
facebook et de twitter lui person who
you tube ce que j'espère ultras brestois
et du coup maintenant tu doutes et
mozilo elo expliquait alors mods et la
philo c'est ben pour promouvoir des
projets qui trouve intéressant pour pour
la société donc là je vais faire un
projet avec eux c'est pour aider les
gens à comprendre quand est-ce qu'ils
sont face à une intelligence
artificielle sur sur sur internet n'est
opposé l'internet et il ya des moments
il va y avoir une autre agence
artistique vous êtes sur youtube qui va
vous recommander des recommandations ou
ça peut être vous êtes sur google et une
autre agence artistique qui va faire
autocomplete qui va vous poser des d
auto complétion de votre recherche
donc comment est-ce que ces
intelligences artificielles elle marche
comment quelles sont les les choses à
savoir quels sont les dangers par
exemple sur sur twitter voilà tout le
danger du trolling si tu ne donnes
liberté à tout le monde et c'est un
algorithme notification basique
forcément le troll qui écrit 100 fois
plus que la personne normale va être vu
même si l'appel du sang fois plus il va
être vu beaucoup plus que ce qui est
faire il donc comment est-ce que
l'algorithme j'ai géré ça et comment toi
en tant qu'humain tu peux comprendre ça
pour utiliser facebook ne twitter mieux
et parce qu'on en pense à l'intelligence
artificielle j'ai souvent ces
discussions où les gens parlent pense à
soi un truc qui n'existe pas un robot
terminator soit les vents pense à des
trucs vraiment un truc très pointue de
la recherche et des envies de plus
associé intelligence artificielle celles
qui sont vraiment utilisé aujourd'hui et
celles qui ont des milliards
d'investissements et des millions
d'utilisateurs soit raciste et une
recommandation complètement exactement
il ya beaucoup de gens qui font de la
science-fiction d'intelligence
artificielle est ce qu'elle sera dans
peut-être 50 ans on sait pas et en fait
moi c'est un peu l'inversé
l'archéologie sur l'intelligence
artificielle
j'explore ce qui a été fait ces
dernières années quel était l'impact de
l'intelligence artificielle sur la
société et les sciences et c est très
pluriséculaire artificiel c'est que les
gens se rendent pas compte que c'est les
intérieurs sortie ciel qui nous avec
lesquels ils interagissent et moi
l'impression que c'est passé si le
téléphone est assez simple être du coup
voilà c'est ça mon projet avec mozilla
c'est le dire à lattes interagit avec
une hotte évidence artificiel mais là
non c'est pas juste un site là il ya une
intelligence artificielle et qui était
programmé pour faire ça tel avantage est
elle un tel danger
son objectif c'est et te laisse pas
avoir et tu peu facile l'exemple
classique j'ai par exemple sur sur
facebook où l'intelligence artificielle
maximiser le temps de vue aussi ils sont
rendus compte que ben légende jusque
rôle et ça marchait bien pourtant eu
mais que ça causait de la dépression une
utilisation passive de facebook génère
la dépression qui le plan d'étude de
fait avoir de facebook facebook et un
moment a décidé de faire des études
eux-mêmes sont ils ont été courageux ils
ont nié publiquement on a fait une étude
l'utilisation massive de facebook créé
de la dépression et ils en ont parlé et
ils ont librement à ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va renforcer au lieu de
renforcer le temps de vue on va
renforcer les interactions entre les
gens parce que justement quand les gens
interagissent entre eux ils se répondent
aux commentaires mais du coup c'est bien
mieux pour l'utilisateur
ouais il donc là c'est un exemple
typique de d'une intelligence
artificielle qui tourne mal et comment
est-ce que tu peut la changer pour que
ça améliore le système et après par
exemple
moi ce que je vais faire
dans mon projet c'est de dire bon ben
maintenant l'intelligence artificielle
de facebook optimiste pour les réponses
le dialogue donc si tu veux avoir
d'impact sur facebook si tu veux que tes
posts soient vus bref le tangage des
dialogues comme ça le but c'est pas
seulement d'avoir le maximum de l'aïd
c'est pas ça qui va faire le plus de ces
soirées comme ça c'est ce sont des choix
qui me frustre avec twitter c'est que le
nom de ritualité de like sont énormes à
maximiser sa et maximisation de sa part
les utilisateurs y compris assez des
moyens de dire quoi que ce soit d'autre
donc ça donne ça ça ça et pour twitter
c'est super délicat de proposer quelque
chose d'autre parce que si c'est baisser
leur stade de tizi el ela éclaire études
sont clairement au centre de pas se
permettre d'essayer de nouveaux trucs
huriez du millier de trucs ici j'ai eu
avait twitté un truc genre ici les like
vous pouvez les mettre
après avoir vu le contenu et de bd la
plus basique que tu peux avoir
et c'est logique si le like été mais
après avoir vu le contenu
il aurait beaucoup plus de poids
beaucoup plus de valeur est-ce qu'ils
étaient dans un succès le son tweet a
été leakée par jack le ceo de twitter
ouais donc laissé le twitter des segway
c'est une bonne idée
il l'a jamais fait moi je peux pas le
faire mais je suis le ceo de twitter je
peux pas le faire mais c'est une très
bonne idée claire et en fait c'est super
délicat qui qui peut faire ça et donc il
faut qu'on ait beaucoup plus de gens qui
se mettent la main à la pâte et qu'ils
allaient mais moi je peux faire des
essais comme ça donc moi je vais aussi
bossé sur créer une crise et c est un
motif voir montrer comment d'autres
d'autres solutions sont viables non ça
c'est super intéressant parce que je
pense que souvent dans le petit que les
gens qui réfléchissent à faire dévier à
bénéfique on va dire
souvent réfléchir à concevoir déjà
bénéfique concevoir des médias pour avec
une burqa soit bénéfique mais le plus
gros défi c'est plus se rendre dès désir
a déjà déployé benfica c'est beaucoup
plus dur que tu travailles avec d'autres
personnes sur ça brûlait sur des trucs
comme ça oui il ya des nages je bosse
avec des amis pour essayer de faire des
choses comme ça donc c'est encore il ya
rien de réponse mais c'est vraiment ce
qu'il ya un peu une communauté de gens
qui font des travaux un peu quand elle
essaie de comprendre saisi ouais donc
après autour du center for human
technology de tristan harris il est du
même système donc à berlin les pas mal
de gens qui se disent bon voilà on peut
faire des design qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient pas toxique
il faut faire comme ça donc lui même
système analyse en forme et les gens qui
sont qui sont maintenant facebook
donc tu as vraiment c'est une mentalité
qui prend de plus en plus ciel de trois
ans c'était juste deux trois hurluberlus
mais s'était vu tu t'es vu quand même
pas mal comme anti tech parlera même de
la tech alors toute éthique nous on
essaye de faire du chiffre on essaie de
faire des vrais trucs lui sont là dans
leurs délires et l'onglet la maintenant
dans les boîtes ils se rendent compte
qu'il ya des vrais problèmes qui sont
créés si on prend pas les tic compte que
pour soi et mila du coup à yahia démont
au sein des entreprises aussi un petit
peu avec ça voilà donc au sein des
entreprises volet youtube lise qui
si l'on me fait vachement demont pour
bosser sur ces problèmes
donc pour l'instant ce qu'ils font je
trouve est pas ça va pas tout
révolutionner la depuis six mois depuis
leur annonce ils ont diminué à peu près
de moitié le nombre de théories du
complot qui acquit du site est gratuite
ouais donc la quantité publicité
gratuite sur les théories du complot
donc ce qui est pas mal parce que c'est
des dizaines de milliards de publicités
gratuites pour ses théories du complot
qui diminue on a vu que sur certains
trucs les théories du complot sont pas
recommandés par l'algorithme sur
d'autres trucs les théories du complot
sont encore vachement recommandé mais
enfin il ya une progression mais c'est
pas ça qui va radicalement changer la
société ça juste impacté les théories du
complot les plus violentes
ouais ben s'il ya besoin de faire
beaucoup plus encore il a besoin de
faire beaucoup plus haut les mains de me
montrer vraiment il ya besoin d'innover
mais on peut pas compter sur les grosses
plates-formes pour rénover maintenant on
est on peut pas compter sur les petites
start-up qui ont pas et qui ont pas les
donner les moyens d'action donc en fait
il ya un énorme trou comment est-ce
qu'on comme tu peux l'utiliser comment
on rend les ia qui existent déjà
bénéfique au lieu d'essayer de vouloir
créer une nouvelle ligue si la personne
donc voila moi c'est qu'elle fut bâtie à
ça les trois prochaines années
bosser à fond là dessus ouais du coup
avec moi maintenant faire face c'est que
non seulement c'est un je pense que
c'est vraiment un problème difficile que
de fixer en prennent très très difficile
moi personnellement je pense qu'il n'y a
pas assez de monde qui travaille au
dessus et même si les bois de sim était
à fond ça serait compliqué parce que
c'est vraiment difficile
du coup je pense qu'ils vont nous ont
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent sur ça
et du coup qui s'est un peu compliqué
mais par exemple dans des chercheurs ken
hicks ça peut être d'autres gens aussi
potentiellement mais faut organiser tout
ça c'est compliqué donc dans nos milieux
qu'ils allaient me qu'on mette des
talents a fait du vélo mais aussi enfin
lors leur but c'est la publication donc
c'est un peu difficile parfois pour eux
de de créer un produit si on veut faire
venir bénéfique vous faire un produit
qui où il ya beaucoup de temps à passer
à configurer et configurer les serveurs
sont énormes et mon truc ces gens
d'affaires en fait c'est qu'ils ont du
mal à avoir les moyens pour payer ça
bien mais il ya aussi des gens géniaux
dans l'académie bossé là dessus donc je
pense que là qu il démis les académies
qui auront leur rôle à jouer
est ce que le gouvernement c'est son
rôle à jouer de ça fait un peu peur le
gouvernement qui veut faire lire ça fait
peur au gens s'assoient gouvernants ont
pas les moyens techniques donc commencé
après pas forcément gouvernante et des
instances publiques voilà mais c'est
après donc comment ce qu'on fait avec
des instances publiques mais sans que ce
soit vraiment le gouvernement qui fait
tilt donc en fait il ya pas mal de gens
qui disent oui il faut que les
gouvernements donnent des sous à des
assos qui font des super truc là dessus
mais moi moi c'est sur quoi j'ai bossé
avec des impacts sur
utiliser le big data pour aider les
chômeurs on a eu des subventions du
gouvernement
c'est juste deux trois petits projets
ici et là donc c'est très peu comparé à
l'étendue des problèmes il ya déjà pas
mal de l'association c'est qu'ils sont
financés par des dons qu'ils entrent hop
voilà donc les philanthropes
en fait c'est une grosse c'est une
grosse médias dessus par exemple une
association d'universitaires et
philanthrope aux états unis qui nomme
avec the night fondation nidaki qui
étaient fondés par des des manades la
presse pour qu'ils ont donné toute leur
fortune pour que pour aider la presse a
mieux marché donc eux ils ont ils font
chaque année donnée par exemple à
stanford à plein d'une diversité pour
faire de la recherche pour comprennent
qu'on comprenne mieux ce qui se passe
sur sur facebook twitter etc
[Musique]
qui sait ça sera vraiment bien je pense
aussi à d'autres organisations comme
open et yahoo qui sont financés par des
marchés en europe qu'à la base quand il
avait un partenariat avec microsoft
donc oui op mais open est encore une
fois laissons pas trop dans le business
de
rendre existantes défis qui sont une
espèce de créer de nouvelles et a et b
défaite donc c'est un peu différent
je pense en effet c'est différent bon ça
serait bien qu'ils ressentent également
sur contre les ja bénéfique mais après
peut-être que s'il ya moins de concevoir
des ponts un peu et justement dans les
cd soit un peu plus des ponts pour
permettre aux gens de collaborer un peu
plus sur ces c'est pour lui qu'ils se
pensent les projets énormes pour
l'humanité parce que c'est
il sera important pour ton ferme ont
pressé un peu plus aussi sûr pas mal de
peut-être des morceaux d'algorithmes qui
peuvent enfin de codes utilisées qui
peuvent être ni open source
pas forcément dans l'optique étant le
type de clarifier ce qui peut être là où
est ce que les gens peuvent plus
facilement insérer des des réflexions
intéressantes tout essayé d'organiser un
peu plus on va choisir des entreprises
comme comme youtube et facebook
je pense qu'elles ont des tâches
vraiment difficile et je pense que en
interne il peut faire des pouvoirs mais
ça suffira sans doute pas et s'ils ont
besoin d'innovation sont eux qui
viennent de l'extérieur et que si sicile
poite capable quasiment de ressources et
un peu ce travail éthique
sinon qu'il doit faire peut-être décédé
c'est à dire que voilà toute façon ils
vont pas il faut se mettre dans la tête
qui vont pas faire ce travail il dit que
même qui vont juste colmater les brèches
quand il ya des gens qui vont se
plaindre de problèmes il y trois
problèmes y
ils vont essayer de colmater pour que ça
soit pas trop là je trouve c'est donc
génial déjà qu'ils qui s'arrêtent de
donner de la publicité gratuite à des
théories du coup absurde qui abat qui
dénonce les propagande d'état
totalitaire
donc ça c'est déjà des oies des pas dans
la bonne direction mais voilà ça c'est
encore que du colmatage et du coup il
faut qu'il faut s'inspirer il faut qu'il
y ait des gens qui lancent les start up
qui essayent voilà qui n'offrent comme
on peut en trouver dans les années 2000
début de l'ère internet mais là je pense
qu'on a une révolution il ya eu la
révolution d'internet et là ce qu'on est
en train de vivre ça va être dans les
cinq prochaines années pour moi ça va
être la révolution de l'eau terme et
éthiques
n'at-il pas fait pour qu'ils en
maximiser le nombre d'utilisateurs sur
un truc donc il va être fait pour
vraiment permettre au jour 2 d'accomplir
leur but quoi ça fait un beau projet
dans la vidéo de ce matin où il
intervient dans les gens se situe
facebook et twitter mais il y avait
quand même
en tout cas l'impression qu'ils avaient
quand même du gros travail parce que
censuré je piste et je pestais kwasi je
laisse tf1 des milliers de comparaître
en titraille sinon oui donc les gens
sont pas compte à quel point oui twitter
youtube facebook ou censure masse une
masse de choses enfin censure entre
lui-même fait c'est pas vraiment de la
censure parce que c'est enfin pour moi
il faut être clair sur ce qu'est la
censure la censure c'est quand tu
empêches quelqu'un de pêche quelqu'un de
s'exprimer d'amérique et d'afrique et
découpé en morceaux
ça c'est de la censure
après si tu es tu peux pas t t'exprimer
sursis un éditeur te dis bon nombre ne
veut pas publier un livre c'est pas de
la censure c'est juste l'éditeur qui
veut pas publiés après si tel
gouvernement qui dit toi tu peux pas
être publiées tournée sinon d'incidents
tu veux tu être découpé en morceaux
ça c'est de la censure et donc quand une
plateforme dit non ça va pas être ici
par exemple voilà facebook pas qu'il
pornographie veut pas quitter ton sur
facebook
est-ce qu'ils censurent les tétons dont
ils ont leurs règles pour leur
plateforme
est ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils aient way
qui est plus de plateformes possibles
toute façon les règles de chaque
plateforme ne vont pas plaire à tout le
monde donc il faut qu'ils puissent de
plate forme pour que tout le monde
trouve des règles qui qui lui
correspondent
donc faut arrêter d'utiliser le terme
censure quand une plateforme veut
enlever un certain type de contenu c'est
leur choix pour moi je trouve ça absurde
qui pas de téton sur facebook mais je
vais pas dire non plus que facebook
censure à plus de modération
voilà donc plus parler de modération un
skull terme de censure en fait c'est
extrêmement important qu'on défende la
société contre la censure
du coup si on utilise le terme censure à
tort et à travers
il perd son sens et du coup quand on
voit comment est ce que tu vas encore le
futur
c'était quand même optimiste ou alors il
ya des choses qui se passent qu'il ya
deux ans on n'aurait pas imaginé ça
[Musique]
réveille dès la reconnaissance de la
reconnaissance des problèmes déjà par
les plateformes grandes avancées a lu
l'article 2 qui dit que youtube sur les
théories du complot
il avait censuré mois au camp des saints
j'ai été très surpris hier et donc bah
oui du coup ça va être bien je pense ça
va bien aussi pour les créateurs de
contenu qui sont juste pas complètement
dès qu'ils sont attachés à la réalité
parce que du coup ça va être plus facile
de capter l'attention s'il n'y a pas
tout cette bourse masque de théories du
complot qui oblige à faire des trucs là
dessus même chez plus c'est avaient
ratissé d'issos qui avait été qui avait
fait une vidéo sur la terre plate moment
il y avait tellement de terre plate que
lui c'est libre veut faire une vidéo sur
internet qu'il avait fait un twist il
n'avait pas vraiment fait une vidéo de
deux des bugs qui avait fait un espèce
de tweets sur la terre plate
du coup c'est la vidéo avait eu vomir
ont vu comme ça du coup sa force tout le
monde a parlé de choses dont on n'aurait
pas on n'a pas envie de parler de terre
plate mais ça c'est un autre problème
faisait s'est fait que notre attention
est limité et que là si on utilise toute
cette attention pour parler de sujets
pendants portant aucune attention pour
le sujet important exactement ça c'est
le point sur quelques mètres avant les
sujets importants
un peu plus et en fait sur la tension
fait l'économie l'économie monétaire est
pas limité on peut avoir des quantités
d'argent illimitée l'économie de
l'attention en fait c'est une ressource
limitée donc en fait les gens raisonnent
un peu dans le même temps même style
donc s'il ya une compétition pour la
tantie la compétition au des terres
c'est bien parce que ça fait baisser les
prix
général c'est bien s'il ya une
compétition pour la tension c'est pas la
même chose parce que comme la tension
est limité si vous voulez faire une
vidéo éducative qui va être vous prendre
plus d'attention que quand des crashs ça
va être assez difficile mais donc le
fait qui est qui et candy clash mois le
camp dit kraft moi même je suis
complètement accro si si je le
désinstalle pas mon téléphone je me
retrouve à passer trop de temps sur caen
micro atx mais moi je suis conscient et
je suis conscient du problème alors pour
quelqu'un türkiye pâquis pack conscient
de ces problèmes d'attention indices us
annoncé moi qui suis suis pas capable de
gérer la convention il faudrait que je
fasse plus gaffe non il faut
désinstaller kandic revers et qu'il est
[Rires]
ce que tu as détruit d'ailleurs pour
j'avais un peu mieux ton attention oui
bah oui tout à fait il ya des en fait
y'a plein de teck qui est génial pour
pour bien gérer la tension
j'utilise une appli pour gérer mais tous
d'où par exemple qui s'appelle thing et
donc c'est payant que c'est 10 euros
mais quand on pense 10 euros pour
organiser sa vie et elle sait rien et ça
marche super bien
j'organise j'utilise par exemple bling
site qui est un bing qui c'est qui est
une app qui te résume des bouquins en un
quart d'heure vingt minutes résumé audio
d'un bouquin pour des trucs de réflexion
pour plein de bouquins s'est passé a
envie de lire tout le livre mais pour
beaucoup de bouquins pour se faire une
idée avant de le lire moi ça m'a permis
de
de lire des centaines de bouquins et
aussi de voir des bouquins de gens qui
pensent pas du tout la même chose que
moi parce que quand tu as qu'avec
l'équipe once les idées complètement
inverse n'a peut-être pas forcément
envie d'acheter leurs livres et passer
des heures à lire mais déjà de pouvoir
voir en vingt minutes on a perçu ça
t'aide à comprendre leur état d'esprit
mais c'est super enrichissant qui en
fait des tonnes et des tonnes
d'abord été développé pour aider
justement à mieux gérer la tension en
général c'est les apps sont payantes et
donc elles ont un peu plus de mal et
commande datant sur les mythes et on les
connaît pas forcément
ouais mais si on doit tout quatre
mentions pense qu'elle peut intéresser
l'argent la litterna savoir comment
gérer la tension
[Musique]
bah en fait sur youtube il ya une
extension qui enlève qui ont l'avenir
commun sur linux donc cette extension
s'appelle ne donne donc de tout ça
permet à la fois sur youtube donc c'est
seulement sur chrome par contre mais ça
permet à la fois sur youtube de
d'effacer les 10 recommandations donc du
cours se fait pas avoir par des
recommandations regarde que les
notifications qu'on a deux chaînes
auxquelles on est abonné et sur facebook
c'est ça m'a aussi beaucoup aidé passé
un truc qui automatisent mis
automatiquement une folle au tout et les
gens que tu suis donc ça vole haut tout
le monde et après j'ai fait juste une
passe dans ma liste d'amis j'ai fait
voilà je suis l'élu et donc ma timeline
maintenant je passe plus de temps sur
facebook parce que ma timeline facebook
l'atlas crawl en 30 secondes
j'ai toutes les informations importantes
pour de temps en temps je rate
un truc mais le truc que je rate par
rapport au nom de trucs que je voulais
pas voir hollander que j'aurai passé à
scrolling et ont fait ridicule donc donc
ne je sais c'est extraordinaire pour moi
ok édition d'aujourd'hui dans la
question parce que question est posée
avant sur quoi est ce que tu vois le
futur dépôt est donc bien le futur en
fait c'est un peu comme avec le tabac
mais que le tabac quand les gens sont
rendus compte que le tabac tue est les
premiers scientifiques seront traités
théoriques parce que le tabac les
personnes mais les marchands de tabac
font disent que c'est n'importe quoi et
ils ont tellement de sous pour faire de
la publicité de leur produits et c'est
qu'on n'arrivera jamais à rivaliser
donc il a fallu des années pour arriver
que les gens se rendent compte que le
tabac c'est toxique est arrivé là se
désintoxiquer landes un peu dans dans la
même logique on se rend compte que moi
il ya plein d'algorithmes qui sont qui
sont toxiques
les marchands de cigarettes ont ils des
filtres sur le cigare pour dire regardez
notre monde est super filtre qui prend
tous les goudrons maintenant c'est plus
toxiques vous pouvez continuer la fumée
c'est bon c'est plus toxiques
il a c'est un peu pareil avec les liens
wikipedia regarder dans ses beaux comme
avant mais je pense qu'il va y avoir
plus en plus de réalisations que voilà
certains algorithmes sont toxiques pour
la société le problème c'est pas les
gens c'est pas
si vous avez quelqu'un qui passe trop de
temps sur youtube le problème c'est pas
lui le problème c'est les algorithmes
qui étaient des années pour faire ça du
coup comment lutter contre ça et comme
tu disais faire un algorithme qui
modèlent gones qui remplace dans ce
plutôt que d'arriver avec quelque chose
de nouveau donc mon égard et je pense
qu'on va y arriver mais pour ça la
première chose c'est c'est que les gens
se rendent ils public et ouais mais ces
réalisations publiques
oui c'est un problème que l'addiction à
la technologie c'est un problème mais
qui vient pas des gens qui vient des
boîtes qui font de la tête tu penses que
pour que les boîtes qu'on attaque change
il faut passer par le grand public
oui forcément sinon on voit que youtube
a changé facebook twitter et youtube ont
changé leur manière de faire quand il
eut des articles de journaux qui sait
des problèmes mais ça c'est un débat
qu'on a quelques légères pertes et
avant-hier sur parce que du coup le
livre avec médias sur wii wheel un titre
ultra ultra depuis techniques ont déjà
certifié le tue pour attirer l'attention
du grand public et tout ça et du coup on
s'est pris un peu des gens qui sont un
peu préoccupé par le fait que ce soit
utilisé à mauvais escient pour juste
ceci ça se comprend parce que en fait
l'intelligence artificielle va permettre
de faire des trucs géniaux par exemple
avec les voitures autonomes
ça va sauver des millions de vies donc
si les gens se disent l'intelligence
artificielle tuent ils vont pas vouloir
développer les voitures autonomes qui
vont se sauver des millions de vie donc
je comprends qu'il est gentil mais je
comprends tout à fait et c'est vraiment
une préoccupation que j'ai fait pas mal
de critiques
mais pense que les bénéfices eux sont
plus importants que les coûts ces coûts
sont importants parce qu'il va falloir
en passer par un peu plus de public mais
c'est ça donc
après voilà faut bien vous bien d'être
la gaffe aux sous titres ou machin pour
sa gaffe à la trouille mais les way je
pense que c'est important que dans ce
que les gens réalisent que dans certains
cas où il était gentil artificielle peut
tu les mets une vidéo de danty
vaccination suggéré à une mère qui vient
d'avoir un enfant et qui est malade et
qui niveau à perdre donc la ligue au
transparent si j'ai fait beaucoup sur
anti-vaccination ça fait deux ans que je
monitor ralenti vaccination est né voilà
il ya deux ans c'était littéralement
youtube de prouver des centaines de
milliers de fois des vidéos qui te
disais que les vaccins sont des années
pour vous tu n'es donc céder
complètement absurde est en fête avec
des vidéos juste avant un montage photo
sha enfin juste des photos de filles
mais c'est l'elysée ma fille avant et
après son vaccin et son autisme
ouais du coup c'était super émouvant
talent et une belle musique tu voyais
cette flics et cette petite flamme qui
étaient quittés magnifique et tu la
voyait devenir autistique et c'était
c'était vraiment horrible et du comment
on disait c'était le vaccin qui avait
causé sa de les deux étaient peut-être à
peu près à la même période et donc si on
peut comprendre que la mère se préoccupe
de sa méthode d'étude scientifique qui
sont posé la question est-ce que ce que
ça se passe et qui ont montré que non il
n'y avait pas de corrélation et le fait
d'avoir cette vidéo en fait elle avait
énormément d'impact elle était vue je
crois un million face à dire qu'elle
était recommandée peut-être 10 millions
foiré
mais c'est juste parce que tu as
quelqu'un qui voit là une impression
il ya rien de scientifique derrière
c'est juste des impressions et des flics
mais qui passe tellement bien que
l'algorithme s'est rendu compte
ah bah ouais si je monte ça à une jeune
maman c'est la meilleure manière de
faire rester les jeunes mamans sur
youtube
je comprends les jeunes banquiers qui
regarde ça parce que j'étais inquiet
pour tomber mais quand même c'est parce
que mon premier bébé pas forcément du
coup l intelligence artificielle peut
tuer travers des recommandations en
formation ben là il y avait le site
avait vu le quai de si bonnes wolf
donc c'était quelqu'un qui passait son
temps à regarder des théories du complot
sur sur youtube qui l'ont janvier a tué
son frère avec une avec un pieu parce
que il pensait que son frère était un
reptile
ouais mais en fait il avait regardé
tellement de vidéos reptilienne sur
youtube que ça lui était monté à la tête
quoi ouais pareil projet peut-être des
drogues ou de trucs mais il était à fond
dans ses théories du complot et qu'il
eût été l promu par par youtube
ouais et est en fait les annonces de
youtube d'arrêter pour voir les théories
du complot de grand chose ces fêtes
telles que ce froid deux semaines après
ça donc ouais parce que là pour ce
qu'elle a en fait il y avait son
historique
youtube qui était en ligne donc envoyé
exactement toutes les vidéos qu'il avait
vu à quel ordre ils ont classe été
extrêmement clair que c'est youtube qui
avait joué un rôle
avec ce qu'il avait fait ce qu'il avait
dit le rôle de youtube était
complètement clairement c'est pour ça
que youtube
ginès c'est parce que notamment
du coup questions qu'elles soient nos
principaux leviers d'action nous deux on
regarde tout ce qui coûte donc ouais
c'est comme tous les grands problèmes
sociétaux donc il ya des levées
d'actions individuelles
c'est à dire moi par exemple je
l'installé 9
je pense que juste savoir que les
intelligences artificielles sont faits
pour se battre pour votre attention
juste savoir ça en fait on se protège on
se dit ah non c'est pas parce que je
veux vraiment et sur youtube c'est que
youtube essaye de laquelle cerveau met
donc rien que ça voir sa cécité à se
protéger avec des trucs comme notch par
exemple utiliser savoir que voilà il ya
des apps qui sont souvent payante mais
qui essaye de faire exactement l'inversé
lui organiser votre temps et votre
attention dans les mx donc rien que ça
voir ça je trouve que c'est un
changement énorme et si on sait déjà
qu'il va le faire sont déjà réaction que
déjà le premier l'idée est là et ça
c'est un peu le après parler des
problèmes quand on voit des problèmes
c'est à dire par exemple on voit en ce
moment ce qui se passe avec youtube ce
que ce marqueur everyday a fait c'est à
dire qu'il a vu j'ai vu un problème j'en
ai parlé
l'analyse et j'ai remonté le problème
comme je pouvais l'être plus il fait des
supers vidéo donc c'était génial bébé
quand on voit des problèmes quand on
voit des trucs bizarres qui se passe sur
youtube juste en parler tu vas faire ça
à certains problèmes légaux rythme lui
ça qui m'a été recommandé c'est
n'importe quoi juste le signal est plus
si vous signez les en privé sur youtube
ou au public sur twitter mais juste
le fait que les gens parlent du problème
c'est énorme atout ou pour après il va
falloir des actions politiques mais là
les politiques sont un peu tellement
déconnecté de l'intérêt qu'ils savent
pas trop comment
et c'est l'épineux avec la liberté
d'expression évidemment donne très envie
de respecter la liberté d'expression et
celle de doit être la priorité numéro
est donc temps en temps voilà il ya des
lois qui ont été faites on se dit bon là
il faut faire gaffe à préserver la
liberté d'expression quand même donc on
résout les problèmes entravant la
liberté d'expression ouais c'est pas
sympa vent compliqué de les voit pas
trop quelle c'est un paradis fiscal bien
légiférer sur ces points c'est complexe
c'est ça c'est pour ça que moi ce que je
veux c'est un la transparence parce que
bon la transparence affecte pas la
liberté d'expression donc si on sait que
google a recommandé l ex jones tant de
millions de fois c'est déjà quelque
chose qui va nous aider c'est à dire
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe sur youtube et si
jamais il se passe des conneries du coup
si elle la transparence les gens vont
voir tout de suite et ça va être corrigé
tout de suite donc c'est pour ça que la
transparence pour moi c'est vraiment le
truc fondamental sur lequel il faut la
transparence nous donc sur pas mal de
statistiques type call you tube
voilà c'est à dire de statistique de
transparence de quel point ils
recommandent de qui donc par exemple une
manière de le faire la transparence
extrêmes ce serait pour chaque vidéo
sache exactement combien de fois at il
recommandé
ça le créateur de la vidéo là ici
combien de fois ces vidéos étaient
recommandés
mais vous savez pas combien de fois les
vidéos des autres créateurs ont été
recommandés et donc là on lui pourrait y
avoir une transparence extrême youtube
veut pas ça parce que de cette
transparence extrême aiderait certaines
personnes à mieux comprendre
l'algorithme est laid mais en même temps
il ya déjà les créateurs de contenu qui
ont déjà des stats et qui peuvent déjà
manipulé l'algorithme web grâce à ses
stats donc en fait c'est pour ça que les
gros médias
je sais pas si tu as vu depuis deux
trois ans les gros médias deviennent de
plus en plus puissant sur youtube les
timbers ce fonds reste reste
relativement petit mais les gros médias
gamecube pourquoi parce que ils ont des
des milliers des milliers de vidéos qui
fait autrement qu'ils ont mis sur
youtube ils ont pu analyser toutes les
stats
ils savent qu'ils marchent et ça veut
faire les titres ta clique parfait et
qu'il soit quand même en ligne avec
leurs lignes éditoriales et du coup ça
donne cette absence de transparence est
vraiment dossier pour les petits
créateurs
là je pense qu il va ya tellement de akp
était accusé youtube qu'on apprend au
fur à mesure en faisant que c'est une
grosse boîte ils les connaissent tous et
je pense que toi tu fais partie d'un
multichannel network nom est en fait
t'as plein de gens qui vont faire partie
d'une multitude de network qu'il a eu
connaît certes un certain ac
donc je sais pas exactement ce qu'ils
font ces multiples donne des trucs mais
en tout cas ils prennent 40 % de son
revenu
donc du coup voilà pour les créateurs
c'est délicat quoi soit il soit ils
passent par sally perdre 40 % de leurs
revenus ils ont beaucoup plus de chances
d'être viraux donc beaucoup de gens le
font pour des conseils du coup parce que
parce que du coup de la motivation de
youtube et a priori tout cas la
motivation par nexans comme l'âme la
méthode n'est pas la bonne s'ils veulent
lutter contre les gens qui arrêtent
leurs études
en fait il devra être ils ont choisi
d'être plutôt opaque et être plus
transparents tu penses que c'est
désagréable
il faudrait qu'il faut qu'il y ait plus
de sens facebook et après au moins sur
les grosses chaînes youtube par exemple
on conserve pas une bataille la droite
américaine qui se dit qu'elle est
censurée par youtube alors alors ça
c'est complètement fou en fait cette
série mute
ils sont pas du tout censurer qu'à voir
les statistiques sur social blaise de
foxnews foxnews été multiplié par quatre
en un ou deux ans sur youtube donc
youtube recommande foxnews énormément et
je pense si ça l'était x 4 c'est surtout
pour ce que je te dis c'est qui ça
prenne les bonnes pratiques
ils font dans la théorie du complot
foxnews dire c'était avant 2016 avant
l'élection de méthane non depuis depuis
les ont énormément des focus donc tu
vois par exemple le dise le dip
il parle du leap state il parle la
lettonie ce que le réchauffement
climatique c'est un hoax donc ils sont
dans peu
rentré dans des thèses un peu con selon
un style un peu conspirationnistes c'est
vachement fox news a percé plus sur
youtube du coup ils sont un peu obligé
de faire ça il est le type ia snippet
sur certaines noël sur certaines vidéos
de foxnews sur réchauffement climatique
il ya le wikipedia snippet et ils sont
en mode complètement théorie du complot
incertaine qui disent oui voilà tous les
scientifiques européens de trucs
les chiffres sur les modèles qui sont
fausses et pas des trucs comme ça parce
que le contrecoup possible d'avoir ce
multimédia snipat c'est que les gens
s'immolent wikipédia fait aussi partie
du complot mutuelle exactions du coup ça
absurde parce que moi je serai un
traître la théorie du complot je me
dirais bah oui totalement dans le
complot et give you tube qui recommande
de faire et ça il le duke gaza mais en
fait ils occupent tu sais pas s'ils sont
en couple parce que si une fois
j'entendais moi ce qui m'étonne toujours
avec les complotistes c'est qu'ils se
disent que s'il y avait ce gros complot
mondial qui essayait de les manipuler
pascal et youtube serait pas dedans quoi
j'aurai un complot mais les urbains qui
n'ont pas pensé à youtube minot tison
pas penser à un filtre et youtube alors
que la terre d'information si on veut
manipuler les gens à youtube c'est
intéressant donc ouais
le truc c'est que s'il y avait un
complot ben youtube serait le premier
truc les illuminati ré infiltrer way et
donc balancer toutes les théories du
complot que tu es là sur youtube sont
fausses puisque ce serait des théories
du complot false flag ont été mises la
part des illuminati pour pas que tu vois
le vrai complot mais s'il ya un ultime
corner
[Rires]
est-ce que tu aurais d'autres roma oui
sûr sur youtube un autre un autre type
que je peux donner c'est simplement
aller sur sa page de souscription en
fait je me rappelle jamais de l'eurl
parce qu'évidemment elle n'est pas
facile à trouver mais tu as une url de
pages de souscription youtube.com cela
je fidh
slash et barney allonge encore une fois
par mois du coup tu peux voir vraiment
qui tue ce serait et puis et puis gsa
enlever ce pas vraiment est sûre de bien
mettre des cloches sur ce qui ce qui
compte vraiment pour toi et en fait on
sature gagne c'est la manière la plus
facile de regagner beaucoup de contrôles
en fait sûr je vais souvent même si je
suis aussi pas mal et qu'on me tue
évidemment mais moi je tombe sur des sur
des pick & click tout en moi le truc qui
me fascine c'est les vidéos d'avion qui
était énorme sur youtube je ne sais pas
pourquoi je peux rester des heures
écoulées des avions à terre et lui le
réveil fut l'âme est attendu sur 30
regards des messages et après youtube
eux jubilent a retenu deux semaines
après ma mort comme andy roddick de même
si on sait que c'est ce qui fait c'est
comme les gens qui fument ils savent que
c'est toxique il le faut du coup s'il
pouvait résumer un peu ces discussions
qu'elle quel est le message clé que tu
aimerais que les auditeurs retiennent
message clé c'est qu'il ya une grosse
bataille pour votre attention qui est en
train de se jouer entre entre les
plateformes la plateforme n'essayez pas
de vous donner le contenu qui est le
meilleur pour vous ils essayent de vous
faire perdre votre temps regardez le
maximum de pub possible
donc je pense que dès qu'on sait que
c'est ce qui se passe sur youtube que
voilà il faut utiliser des outils pour
mieux apprendre à gérer son temps mieux
pas trop voir de deux recommandations
toxiques et quand on les voit pas cliqué
dessus ainsi on apprend du oui est ce
que je dois finir avec des
recommandations de vidéos podcasts
livres ou personnes à suivre
ouais donc un peu de caisse qui
s'appelle yoann divided atention qui
fait par tristan asie tristan arrêt
c'est elsa raskin donc été très
intéressant justement tout sur ces
problèmes d'attention et de cette course
7 course à la tension je remercie
beaucoup de gars guillaume et merci vous
à l'éditeur et je dis à bientôt pour une
prochaine fois
probablement